The Joe Rogan Experience I don't think
these are happy people all the people
you mentioned I don't I don't know that
they were happy I don't know that I'm
not happy so you know and I and I'm this
goofy but you seem happy I know you seem
happy when you're around people
um that's what's the scariest thing yeah
I'm nobody's more confused than me and
right now as I talk to you I'm
incredibly medicated and I I am what do
they get you on I'm not talking about
what I'm on because people uh it may not
be good for you and I don't want people
to take well that's very admirable of
you yeah but I do I get help I'm
surrounded by people the dichotomy
between how I feel and what I do is huge
you know I'm I'm a [__] mess and you
know I deal with depression and anxiety
it's unfortunate because you're such a
nice guy every encounter I've ever had
with you has been so pleasant so fun and
so nice I always walk away going Howie
is like the nicest [__] guy thank you
I always feel that way so hear about a
person like you that doesn't feel well
well that's that gets depressed I'm like
God damn it when he's around people he
seems so happy
I'll tell you why because like in this
moment I'm talking to you so what I'm in
this moment you know listening to you
responding to you
um right now you're happy I'm distracted
you know so I am because the worst thing
for me is quiet time you know I don't
like I don't like night time I don't
like when I get into my own head that's
why I like stand-up comedy because in
those moments you're just in the moment
because you have to be you know I could
if I veered off into the darkness that
is me and not listening to a word you're
saying and not trying to respond I'm
just trying to you know I feel like I'm
balancing on this little ledge all the
time and these words and these
interactions hold me are my cable that
hold me on this side of it without
falling off
wow it's heavy it is heavy you know uh
it's like uh OCD has become a vernacular
for a joke I can't tell you how many
times a day somebody comes up to me and
they go you know I'm a little OC dish I
want all my stuff lined up I like to
stay clean too that's not OCD right
that's they've used that as a word for
being fastidious or neat OCD slightly
compulsive
it's not obsessive compulsive well the
obsession is the part that when you are
obsessed with a thought and you can't
get a thought out of your head no matter
how dark it is or you can't get a ritual
out of your head and you can't move on
you think about Howard Hughes was
probably one of the brightest most
productive
engineering you know marvels of our time
and so many in technology and and
Artistry and everything and his last few
years he was in the fetal position naked
in his room pissing into a bottle
right and I tell people in at any given
moment when you're with me I can't tell
you I'm not that far from that so I'm
always just trying to toe the line and
be on this side of that door you know
have you done any anything else that
helps other than meditation have you
tried um other than medication have you
tried meditation
I tried it I've tried meditation and I
do meditation I've tried Medica
meditative I've tried everything outside
of the uh and I'm not opposed to it
um the psychedelics and mushrooms and
things like that I don't know if anybody
would recommend that to you well here's
the here's the problem for me in order
to do that you'd have to get off your
medication right and to get off my I
don't know that I could survive that
bridge from my medication to doing that
so the medication is for me my my
lifeline so you would have to be like
very very closely supervised during that
entire time I wouldn't I wouldn't know
how anyone would approach something like
that because I think you're you're
dealing with a very specific kind of
case and most of the people that
advocate for psychedelics do not
Advocate Advocate it for people that are
really struggling not like mentally we
might just to keep it together right now
you know and to get off the medication
which is helping you keep it together it
probably doesn't seem wise but there's
ways you can do it without drugs and
there's like holotropic breed thing
there's some people who practice I I
have never experienced this so this is
me talking about my ass but I have
direct connections to people that have
done Kundalini Yoga there's a specific
style of Kundalini Yoga specific way
that you can achieve these bizarre
um States Altered States that similar
they're similar to like mushrooms or a
DMT experience they're similar to
psyched dogs according to people that I
know that have actually done the
psychedelics and have gotten obsessed
with Kundalini and they say they can get
to that place on their own which if you
know somebody then give me a card before
I leave here today I do not know anybody
well I know of some martial artists that
have done it but they don't teach it but
I do know that there's a great place in
La that teaches Kundalini Yoga well if
anybody's listening to this and and
you're I'll read the comments if you
have any recommendations yeah I again
this is not I don't have personal
experience with this so I'm just
relaying other people's anecdotes and
seems interesting
um but regular yoga for me I really like
but running I use it as a meditation I
just I don't even listen to music I just
listen to the my I do it on the
treadmill and I just listen to my feet
hitting the treadmill and my breath and
I'll do that for an hour that's amazing
every day that's that's fantastic it's
good for my physical health but it's
also better for my mental health so to
me that's kind of a medication
medication it is yeah it is a medication
and a meditation and uh just staying
crazy busy is is my other form of uh I'm
really busy that's good though it seems
like everything you're doing you enjoy
so even though you're busy you're busy
doing fun stuff I I most of the time but
I have it like at this uh this uh
overlay of Terror to think whatever I'm
doing is going to end whatever I'm doing
will get me in trouble you know like the
truth of the matter is when I found
stand up stand up was the most freeing
thing in the world it was the one place
where unlike you know acting I didn't
have to recite any lines I didn't have
to hit any marks you could do anything
and that's why I've been such an
advocate for you and all the people that
we talked about earlier because they
seem to be incredibly free